After centuries of following the tumultuous course of the great rivers, this young civilization took to the sea, which brought it to the shore of a distant isle, Crete, a center of prosperity and culturally well ahead of its time.
The newest discovery, hopscotch. It's so simple. Watch.
Now you, my son.
Nice dress, my dear. You look simply ravishing. Thanks.
Oh, look what they're doing.
But wasn't it MacAdam who invented tar for road paving 3,000 years later?
Careful where you step.
Listen, let me tell you what happened to my ancestor at Mohenjo-Daro.
Every word's true, I swear.
Oh, the moral is, always look where you put your feet.
Wanna try that?
Nothing serious.
Well, I hope Dad'll teach him a lesson.
Thanks, maestro.
It's nothing, my boy.
You'll pay attention from now on?
Yep.
May we take a peek?
Why, sure.
Go right ahead.
Make a look.
There's a real treasure.
I've had a brainstorm.
Really?
Why don't you use both hands? Wouldn't that be much more practical?
But that's impossible. How'd you expect the wheel to turn if I work with both my hands?
Why, with your foot like this.
Here, show him, my boy.
That's progress for you.
Manual labor is out, and the industrial era has already begun.
Baths, running water, other conveniences.
Even 3,000 years later, Louis XIV of France wouldn't be this lucky.
What? No bloodthirsty gods? No conquering army? No war? Just happiness? Prosperity and pleasure?
How could that be?
Well, as we see, it's too good to be true.
The Achaeans from Mycena have just invaded Crete,
and from which they will adopt their art of living, their entire civilization.
Crete, Greece, Sparta, Mycena, Athens.
500 years before our time, Athens was a young democracy.
A democracy.
And in the enormous Persian Empire not far away,
the great king Darius I was building magnificent palaces in Persopolis,
while somewhere in the Far East lived Buddha and Confucius.
But let's get back to Greece.
In the year 450, Socrates was 20 years old.
Pericles was 45.
In 450 BC, Pericles spoke these words.
A real democratic state must, without exception, serve the greater number.
For each and all, equality before the law.
It must avoid any show of individual egoism
and protect the individual from arbitrary decisions.
Hooray!
Very good.
Step this way, sizzling sausages, when should they stem, you'll agree, you've never come across anything, come on, come on, come on, come on, say, and you never will, never in your life, come and get your sizzling sausages.
Welcome to the theater, my friends. Today, we will treat you to my very latest play, Antigone. As you'll see, I've added a few new features.
Now, it's time to consult the stars. The Big Dipper, and that one, whatchamacallit? Ah, of course.
Ah, but what in heaven's name, I think I've got it.
Super, super, two lines, yeah?
What's up there?
Oh, yes, certainly. Pardon me how silly of me.
Oh, that's wrong. That's impossible.
Give it a little thought.
If you're gonna be that way about it.
Oh, that's just perfect.
Go up and sit next to her.
What you waiting for? Sit down.
Who wants to share my fate in the legacy of evil Edibus that's bequeathed me?
Do you think Zeus will set us free?
Oh, the most beautiful sun that ever shone on Thebes' seven gates.
They breaking at last over the rustling rivulets of Deersay.
And he who has led them to our soil is Polynesi the rebel, none other.
An enemy in death is still an enemy.
Yes, always an enemy.
I was put on earth to give, to share love, not hate.
Then descend, and if you must needs love, then love the dead.
While I breathe, there will be no woman who makes the law.
Resumptuous ones, struck down by fate, pay dearly for their boasting, too late comes wisdom, they're lucky.
Met a young maiden, sir.
Could you possibly tell me, sir, whether the gods would approve my marrying her?
Please follow me, we must consult Pythia.
Yes, my boy, the gods are quite favorable.
Aphrodite, goddess of love.
Hera, the wife of Zeus, as well as Athena, his daughter.
Return to your chamber. This is not meant to be overheard by a woman.
All visitors are welcome in my house.
Glory to Zeus.
At a play, I happened to meet your fair daughter. I asked her hand in marriage.
You consulted the oracle?
Mm-hmm.
Oh, a little bit fragile, this thing, I think.
So, the oracle is favorable.
Very well, then. We're agreed.
I'm just gonna make it snappy.
Your daughter.
So sorry.
You're much too late.
After, an olive branch announces a happy event.
The election procedure is as follows:
Mark an X on your tablets next to your choice, then we'll total up all the votes.
The position has been adopted.
Who'll make me an offer for this fine athlete?
No, no, no, no.
What if I throw in this poor orphan girl on special?
I'll take it, I'll take it, I'll take it, I'll take it!
This one's not bad at all.
49 BC, a peace treaty has been signed between Athens and Persia.
The Acropolis is being rebuilt.
If you'll take my advice, this temple...
Just a minute.
I see it large, roomy, classical, tall column, the fronton, follow sort of like that.
Hold on.
I've saved this as a surprise.
See this?
Don't worry about any of this.
Trust me.
Lower.
This was made with Sparta in the year 446.
And life picked up and went on as usual.
It's usual good-natured pranks.
What's an intro?
I think he's gonna be back.
So much for Spartan weddings.
So much for Spartan education, let's return to Athens.
The city is being rebuilt once again.
In Sparta,
and that's enough of Spartan education.
Work on the Acropolis is almost finished.
The School of Arts and Letters, training ground for tomorrow's elite citizens.
Completed my peroration.
My son, come with me.
Up to the Acropolis.
And friends, I simply must show you my work.
A statue of Athena, the Parthenon.
Oh, it's not too bad, really.
In fact, if all of it isn't Socrates.
Hello.
Tell me, my son, tell me what you know.
Nothing is all.
You admit knowing nothing, believe me, you have the key, the basis of all knowledge.
Come, Socrates, come with me.
I have a few ideas you might like to debate.
Over here we have...
Coming with us?
No, no, no, boys.
This time you go into classes alone.
I've got something else I've got to do.
Athenian democracy was as large as the Duchy of Luxembourg,
its citizens numbering 40,000. Your average Athenian was certainly not perfect, far from it.
Aristocrates, the expansionist, felt that slavery was a normal thing, although Hippocrates, the
father of modern medicine, and Herodotus and Thucydides, the first historians, at least they
saw to it that time didn't erase what man had accomplished. Euripides, Medea, Andromache,
Trojan women, Orestes, and so many more, Sophocles, Antigone, Ajax, Electra, Edyphus the king,
and others. Protagoras,
man is the measure of all things.
It is he who decides what is or isn't.
Anaxagoras, intelligence is the world's
guiding factor. Socrates,
know thyself, brought philosophy within reach
of ordinary men. Phidias,
ah, Phidias, this creator
of many marvels, please,
who brought all these men together.
As before another such gathering of luminaries
would occur, 2,000 years
or more, to Zeus, and
as was the case every four years since
776, the Olympic Games.
The 87th Games to be precise.
Games which enabled people from all over Greece to meet would soon give way to less peaceable encounters.
4:31. Athens' expansion was now encroaching on other cities. Once again war with Sparta.
Please, promise me you'll take care.
Hi, Mom.
Athenian. Pitted against Spartans.
29. Like so many others.
Heracles died of a plague.
Greece became swept up in endless and suicidal wars.
And yet the nation's heart still beat.
Democritus created the atom.
Pocrates, medicine. Aristophanes, comedy.
Alcibiades, the master of duplicity.
As for Socrates, things weren't exactly rosy. Accused of impiety and corrupting the youth, he was sentenced to death.
Yes, in their own way, those Athenians were odd, condemning Socrates, the universal mind, to death.
But not only him, nearly every other innovative mind at the time was outcast or exiled.
The just and Miltiades, victors of Marathon.
Mysticles, who triumphed at Salamis.
Admiral of the Delos League.
Alcibiades the perverse, Lucidides historian in general, well, Anaxidurus, because he believed that the earth rests on air and the sun is an incandescent mass, Protagoras the measure of all things man, because he was an unbeliever, Euripides whose plays were smash hits, and Phidias, Phidias who brought stone to life, Heracles and Socrates, after Socrates came Plato, after Plato Aristotle, and in 338 when Philip of Macedon, a long lost cousin, took Greece under his wing and reunited it.
it was aristotle who was chosen to educate his son alexander strange coincidence meeting of two
great minds one to teach one to conquer strange a unique greek spirit became lost in the immense
empire of alexander the great and stayed lost like man it had its limits greek philosophy science and
art laid dormant for two thousand years only to awaken later like sleeping beauty and continue
where they'd left on